feel like I need to have a chat with
Miss Sarah Cameron here because let's
unpack she does John be dirty and she
cheats on him here's the thing and that
was that was why I was so scared about
this the storyline because I felt like
that inherently wasn't in Sarah's nature
and so why I wanted to make it feel like
ultimately ultimately
she was so lost and so confused by what
was going on and you know when you know
just like you know John P has been
Sarah's home she gets kicked out of that
home figuratively where does she go you
know like she in the arms of her ex she
has the no she has she has nowhere to go
like you know her friend like she can't
stay with her friends and she runs you
know she's kind of like she's kind of on
her own and you know what does that do
to someone and it's it's hard and you
you tend to go towards you know the
person who will welcome you you know I
think that's a very human thing I think
that's very you know and it's
complicated it's just like any
relationship is
really aren't clear
[Music]
foreign
yeah and it's not like it was
intentional right you know it was it
never ever never ever I think that was
that was my one thing like this cannot
just be like straight up Sarah just
decides one day right right you know
cheating is never warranted but John B
does her dirty too like the whole
conversation at the Chateau and in the
way that he goes about it
um I'm not warranting it but you know
two wrongs don't make it right there's
like a lot of back and forth though they
need to get there to go do you think
though at the end of the day like do you
think John B and Sarah are end game by
the end of season three I do I think I
think that that's I think that's kind of
been clear you know since day one in my
opinion but I think
but I think just like you know fairy
tale relationships are wonderful and
everybody dreams of it but they're also
still real relationships in real life
that deal with real problems and it's
all about how you get through it do you
think they're end game I I like to think
so what about the feud with topper
though I mean punching your real life
friend that scene in particular what was
that like what did you have to channel
in that moment
you know I I had to like take Austin out
of the equation
but it was it's tough you know because
like you're literally throwing punches
that are missing his face by you know an
inch and then by the end when they yell
cut I'm like rushing the grass off of
his face and like making sure his hair
is back and I'm like are you okay like
holding his face as if I'm gonna kiss
him I'm like you're good okay and then
like picking him up I'm like I didn't I
didn't like push you too hard he's like
I don't know so
um so much it's all about but yeah those
those scenes are it's it sucks you know
at times it feels real you know you you
get so deep into these characters and
there's so many moments where the lines
get blurred so you know you kind of got
to snap out of it afterwards and me
awesome and mads just kind of sat in the
van after that and we're like well that
was crazy
I feel like I need to have a little chat
with Miss Cameron because she's she's in
between men here we've got a little love
triangle happy I'm gonna lead me on or
lead topper on it
I think she's leading both on that's the
thing and it's like frustrating as a fan
to watch because it's like that young
love you cheater totter between two
different people who do you hope is end
game for Sarah
obviously Toppers on in a good place I
think maybe he needs to move on I think
I don't know but
obviously all those emotions come back
in this season and it's cool to kind of
see them get back to the bonfire with
the Kooks and and kind of a sense of
normality but all those emotions do Rush
at one time and you know I think she's
torn in a way she finally realizes that
everything that I've done that seems
controlling is all out of love you know
for her and
um we'll see what's to come so do you as
Austin no relation to topper here do you
from an outside perspective want Sarah
to end up with topper or do you have a
little spot in your heart that you think
John B is end game
I I don't I'm torn I'm torn myself I
can't I can't answer that I think
neither I think neither yeah I don't
think I don't think any of it's healthy
I don't know because she's technically
married to John B but wouldn't tell
topper I want to tell topper I think she
needs to like chill she's crying she's
crazy but maybe maybe like she just
needs to have a season of herself yeah
right yeah it just takes some time alone
I can help you
[Music]
you
have to help my son we learn at the end
of season two that John B's dad is alive
but you're going to have an emotional
reunion with your TV Dad how is his
existence literally going to shake
things up in season three I think it
changes everything it changes the entire
direction of the show it changes the
dynamic between the friends the
relationships and it really causes a
stir and it'll be interesting to see how
The Pogues in the world of the show sort
of bounce back from from this huge
Revelation it
one for him to have been without his dad
and seeing The Pogues be there for him
for that and
I mean when when your dad's been gone
that long I mean I think he he maybe
built up expectations or something it's
it's throws a whole wrench in it when he
gets back and maybe he's not exactly
what
John B remembered or expected and having
him back will like shake up the Dynamics
between relationships too and the first
thing that came to my mind is John B and
Sarah yeah because now there's a father
in the picture yeah yeah we were talking
about you know like how um John B has
kind of become you know and The Pogues
have become Sarah's new home like you
know home and family has kind of been
redefined for her and so
um and so I think that that's kind of
like that's been
that's been her her Touchstone you know
is is are those relationships and um
where are those friendships in that
relationship and I think you know when
when John B's dad comes back into the
picture it definitely shakes things up
and like you know and how to like not
hierarchy but like how to you know how
to
I don't know how to handle those two
relationships that are obviously
priority
um so yeah I think it definitely causes
a little bit of tension you know the new
Love Club
yeah
I quit
there is a lot of love in the show too
with your characters with Cleo and Pope
because I feel like it's like
teeter-tottering will they or won't they
will they or won't they they grow with
this Foundation by the end of season
three
will they be a thing
I think they're still uh working through
it I think Pope gives her home I think
Cleo being an orphan and not growing up
with a family I think him and the
haywards really give her a family and
something to hold on to and I think he
is her family and I think he shows her
love in a way that she didn't experience
and I think that makes her vulnerable
and I think
you know maybe she'll find a way to you
know let her I think he brings out a
softness in her that no one else can
then we have Pope and Cleo will they or
won't they I guess fans will have to
watch and find out no come on give me a
little something are we are we are we
seeing though like uh the foundation for
a relationship lost in there well you
know it's like all the best
relationships start with really really
good friendships you know and they're
definitely building that friendship now
and I think you know you can start to
see a little bit of the Sparks you know
they definitely have a lot of
similarities and like their past
relationships and like the things
they've wanted you know she's uh opening
up to him and I don't think she normally
does that with a lot of people so I can
definitely could see uh some Sparks I'm
on board I would love to see that yeah
dude that's why I asked like will they
or won't they like oh my god oh the show
gives you that okay well I love that you
said the best relationships Star as
friendships because we see that with JJ
and key I mean talk about building a
friendship that evolves into a
relationship I mean they finally
exchanged their first kiss I love yous
the whole rule of no Pogue on Pogue
macking is totally out the window at
this point yeah yeah again it wasn't it
was never a rule as much as it was a
guideline a guideline yep where do we
see this relationship evolve to I think
it evolves from a um I think where it's
going it's a little something to work
there's a little hope uh for like just
what they're trying to find and I think
JJ's really confused this season I think
JJ's really confused and he doesn't know
where he's going in life and um the
character that's there from this season
is Kiara and so you know I don't know
exactly what that means I don't have my
crystal ball but uh you know the writers
really clocked it this yeah he's at home
I was like wait are you looking for the
crystal ball
sure yeah I'm filming too but um yeah
it's you know the writers clock that's
something uh that the fans really wanted
that this season so like I feel like I'm
excited for them to watch it and I hope
they enjoy it will we see Rafe ever find
love is that a possibility or is like
that storyline so far off the path I
don't know I mean yeah is he capable of
it you know it's like yes Rivas learned
to love himself before he can love
anyone else so I think he needs to go on
his own Journey before before diving
into any relationships see we're talking
about with Sarah too so maybe the
brother
who's maybe Cameron cameras are off the
rail cameras we need help and they need
to uh yeah they need I don't know
they're the problem yeah Toppers
marriage counselors well speaking of off
the rails though we do see topper light
The Pogues house on fire after Sarah
betrays him so I mean
to what lengths will topper go to also
seek revenge there's some there's a lot
happening this season yeah yeah here
there here there back and forth no doubt
yeah it's
you're seeing that side of topper that I
think you saw in season one the
controlling you know doesn't know how to
control his anger part of of himself and
season two I think he was you know a
little more relaxed obviously just kind
of wanted to make sure Sarah is okay and
she's healthy and season three I you
know he got let on he he got his hopes
up and
completely fell back in love with her
and and to see that betrayal was a lot
and that's how I ended up reacting which
is a lot but um you know we'll see if
John B finds out who did it when you
both read the end of season three
what was your reaction and how would you
describe it for the fans
it was emotional it's emotional it is
emotional I mean like I mean yeah
there's like the the immediate reaction
to be like oh God it's coming you know
yeah we're we're you know we're gonna
end the season holy but
um I think also exciting just to see how
the World's Gonna you know hopefully
start expanding um you know it's getting
you know you think you get to the end of
it and and you're like okay there's no
more to do and then you know our show
Runners have a really good good
imaginations about ways to to further it
Gold's still out there I was literally
just gonna ask do we finally see the
gold come home
[Music]